[Musik]
das klingt abgefahren das klingt
kompliziert das klingt nach chemie aber
ist eigentlich ganz einfach das können
eigentlich alle machen und ein paar
tricks möchte ich ihnen zeigen und das
ist einfach das nützen der molekularen
eigenschaften von lebensmittel und genau
das ist eigentlich das was damit der
molekularküche eigentlich möchte dass
man geschmack und aroma auf dem buch
bringt und das sieht man schon die
ersten experiment wir wollen heute einen
kaviar machen aus bierglases
lebensmittel
wir geben bisschen räucherfisch dazu
klassisches lebensmittel pumpernickel
klassisches lebensmittel die butter
kräuter york das ist ja alles das was
sie aus der küche sowie so können bis
auch diese so was heute machen wir
wollen also bier in kugelform bringen
das ist der kariya und was ist kari
haakana ist ihr flüssig und hier fest
als hat eine feste haut wie bekomme ich
diese haut fest um das bier zu
verkapseln müssen wir das bier zunächst
mal in der flüssigen form in dieses glas
gießen und das sieht man schon dass
schäumt also richtig gut auf und das
stört eigentlich in diesem fall deswegen
ist das wirklich wichtig dass man diesen
schritt einfach am abend vorbereitet das
sich eben der schaum dann setzt und dann
gebe hier in dieses 4
natrium alginat das ist das pektin der
algen hat die gleiche funktion in der
zelle und man geht dann eben mit dem
stabmixer reihen
und sein solange einfach bis dieses
radio alginat an ihnen die sind hier
ausgelöst dass software keine klumpen
der sich das alginat ist ein polymer
dass sie ungefähr so aus ich mag das
einfach mal schäfer bild und da ist ein
zweites politiker sieht dass ich sie
genauso aus das sind lange ketten die
lösen sich in diesem bier
das macht das bier dickflüssig das haben
wir gesehen als ist flüssiger und jetzt
kommt es kalt wird
dazu habe ich hier dann kalzium laktat
das ist also ein anderes sauer prüfen
das ist das salz an dass das salz der
milchsäure mit kalzium
kalzium ist wichtig weil calcium ist im
gegensatz zum natrium 2 wer regionen
also in zweifach positiv geladen und
davon von diesem kalzium salz gebe ich
sozusagen hier etwas in dieses wasser
sodass war es das calcium laktat das
bekommt man auch wie eben auch das
natrium alginat im online-handel in
spezial shops aber das bekommt man
heutzutage überall im internet
jetzt muss ich noch ein bisschen
umrühren es ist das löst und dann kann
man loslegen lassen dieses diese
kügelchen jahr in das calcium bad von
calcium ist ein zweijähriges schon das
stimmt in dieser lösung herum und das
kalzium das ist ca zwei plus eins muss
man einfach eins und eins zusammenzählen
weil diese stellen hierbei diesem
alginat die sind einfach negativ geladen
hier einfach negativ geladen und das
calcium ist zweifach positiv geladen man
muss sich da auch ein bisschen einfach
auch einschließen so zu sagen dass man
das gefühl hat wie stark drückt man da
wie groß werden die das ist immer ein
bisschen unterschiedlich das hängt immer
auch von der viskosität erlösung ab der
bi lösung
dieses kalzium das sucht sie hier diese
ladung aus dann bleibt plus eine ladung
übrig und die stadt sich dieses polymer
dann hat man plötzlich hat man dann
praktisch hier eine verbindung zwischen
diesen molekülen das sieht aus wie so
eine eierschachteln bei den alle
kalziumionen hier drin sitzen und
sozusagen eine feste ionische bindung
veranstalten
das heißt also wir haben all diese
ketten verbunden über diese kalzium
bindung und genau das ist diese hülle in
dem anfang nicht so perfekt sind hier
sind sie tatsächlich nicht so perfekt
wie es eben auch nicht so tragisch
übung macht eben die molekularküche
man könnte diesen kaviar ist endlich
auch einfach so löffeln das wäre
natürlich football
deswegen wird natürlich der kaviar in
szene gesetzt haben sich ein schoenes
cafe be your kräuter fisch pumpernickel
also fast klassisch nur eben ein
bisschen anders und das ist eben auch
die molekularküche
[Musik]